we're here with jeanette wing
uh jeanette tell us a little bit about
your background you have a very strong
academic background
yes i was at carnegie mellon
university for over 27 years where i was
department head twice
and before that i was actually at the
university of southern california for
two years
and i got all my degrees at mit
so i have been in academia for basically
my whole career my whole professional
life
i did have a stint at the national
science foundation for three years
and that exposed me to how
dc really works and what was the path
that led you here to microsoft
well i i have always had friends at
microsoft
certainly rick rashid was
at carnegie mellon when i was a very
young faculty member
and i saw him be swooped up by microsoft
to start microsoft research
and i have watched from afar
in academia of how microsoft research
grew up
over the 20 to 23 years now and so
i've always been a friend of microsoft
um
and also i myself spent a sabbatical at
microsoft research
in 2002 2003 and i had a great time
and what were the things that interested
you most about microsoft research
well as a an academic as
a researcher myself there were two
areas of research that overlapped
in in my interest with microsoft
research one was
the whole trustworthy computing effort
that was going on and that started with
bill gates 2001 memo
and in fact that's what brought me to
microsoft research in 2002 2003 because
i read that memo and i said well what
does trustworthy computing
really mean and i figured the only way
i'm going to find
out is if i come to microsoft research
and
work within microsoft research to find
out what twc really means
and the other area of interest research
interests that overlap
is actually the group that hosted me was
run by jim larris it was the software
productivity
tools group or something like that spt
and at the time
they were showing how formal methods
which is my
first research area of interest in terms
of
theorem proving and model checking and
static analysis
could be used in practice to scale
and it was the heyday of the slam
project
and i was very lucky i felt very lucky
to be
here when all of that tech transfer was
happening between microsoft research
and the rest of the company what is
computational thinking
computational thinking is the thought
processes
for formulating a problem and expressing
a solution to that problem
in a way that a computer a human or a
machine
can effectively carry out now that's
quite a mouthful of a definition
and i used words like effectively
solution problem expressing
quite carefully because there are
technical
meanings to those terms but let me put
it
more simply i like to think of
computational thinking
as just the thought processes that a
computer scientist
would use in solving a problem
and that begs the question of
what are those ways a computer scientist
approaches problem solving
and many of the ways that we learn in
computer science just
you know concepts but the most important
thought process that all computer
scientists use
in problem solving is abstraction
the ability to ignore all the
irrelevant complex details
of the problem at hand and look
at a higher level of what are the
relevant
parts of the problem that i need to
tackle that i need to address
and the ability to decompose a problem
into smaller pieces
solve the smaller pieces and put
together a solution to the whole problem
by putting together the solution to the
smaller pieces
those kinds of um think
thought processes of abstraction
decomposition
composition are the bread and butter
techniques of a computer scientist kind
of on a day-to-day basis
and i strongly believe that anyone and
everyone
can learn these concepts and learn and
how to use them and apply them in
daily life at what age is it appropriate
for a child to begin thinking this way
and how does one become
better at computational thinking
well i have been advocating that
computational thinking is for
everyone and i
think that already from
the undergraduate programs through
graduate programs and
beyond people have already
embraced the importance of computational
thinking
so now the challenge is to address
the k-12 level now what would it mean
to teach a kindergartner
what computer science is and what good
computing
can do for him or her when you're five
years old
um and i i think that's still an
interesting research question not just
for computer scientists in fact
but i would challenge the education
scientists the cognitive scientists
the learning science test to
ask the question what kind of
computing concepts would make sense to
teach to a kindergartner
and i think they're actually already
programs out there
that address that question
so for instance there's a program out
there
called cs unplugged which is teaching
little kids all about computer science
without a computer
so for instance you can teach a sorting
algorithm
by lining up a whole bunch of kids and
you know telling them they need to be
sorted in a particular way
and maybe they discover how to sort
themselves
um you know like the height of the the
children
and maybe they discover on their own a
particular sorting algorithm and then
you can ask
is there a more efficient way you know
and so they can actually discover on
their own
the different kinds of sorting
algorithms interesting so
this might date me but i remember when i
was a child reading stories about how
big a computational problem dna
sequencing was for example and that it
might not even be done in my lifetime
um and in hindsight that's kind of
laughable
what are the big problems that we're
facing today what are the big data
problems that
uh that are the equivalent of that
well so big data is uh clearly a
buzzword these days
and i think that uh
certainly every um
sector every science every engineering
discipline
every you know professional sector when
i say sector law
medicine humanities um
and then all the sciences astronomy
biology and so on
they are facing this big data
problem in in terms of um
generating lots of data with say
scientific instruments
like the large hadron collider
collecting lots of data
through sensors so we've got
sensor nets that span the globe
all in real time collecting lots of
data um and then
processing all this data and then
generating
uh metadata on top of that
and you can imagine and that's just say
for one scientific
uh discipline now you'd like to put it
all together
um you'd like um
uh different
straight in principle you'd like all
these streams of data
to come together and all of us to make
some
sense out of it and
i like to talk about not just big data
but i like to talk about
from data to knowledge to action
so from all this data which is just a
lot of bits
you'd like to actually extract some
interesting information some knowledge
some semantics from this data and then
from the representation of that
knowledge and it's usually going to be
visual a human being or some bot
eventually will make a decision make an
intelligent
decision um on that knowledge
so the one example is
if we look at some work for instance
being done at microsoft research
in climate modeling we've got
lots of data that different
government agencies collect in terms of
weather
and soil and
you know um uh um
air and wind and so on imagine all of
this data being put together
in a way that we can predict
what when to plant what crop
so we have the capability we have this
information
the information sources and in the end
you want someone to make that decision
you know we need to plant
you know more soybeans here
at this time of year um in this region
and and and so that's where we're going
with
the big data now right now we're
we're so concerned with the big data
part
we're forgetting that what we really
want is data to knowledge the action
so by by my saying we're so consumed by
the big data part
i mean that we're thinking all this data
we have to store all this data we have
to
process all this data but in the end
you want to represent the knowledge
that's
inherent in all the bits um
in a way that a human being in the end
will make some intelligent decision and
so we're
i think where we're going i i think
we're very conservative
data now but i think any very soon we'll
start talking
talking more about intelligent decision
making
or visualization of this data so that
near human beings can make these
decisions
can actually act on the knowledge that's
represented by the data
it's pretty standard for executives to
um to rave about the talent that they
have
under them but you know we also like
metrics so if i
challenge you and say you know prove it
what what are the things that you would
tell me about
the researchers at msr microsoft
research
has a stellar academic reputation
and one of the standard metrics
whether we like it or not in terms of
evaluating the quality of research
coming out of an organization or the
quality of the researchers
who produce the research is of course
publications
and microsoft research microsoft
researchers
are way up there in terms of conference
and general publications
in the highest quality
venues that's one metric it's a
stand-in actually for what i think is a
more important metric in research
but harder to quantify which is the
impact
of a person's research
at the impact of an organization's
research
there again i still think that microsoft
partly by the sheer size of microsoft
research as an organization
has had a tremendous impact on the
advances of science one of the groups
within msr
is the rise team who've been very active
in the developer community and they've
created and released some amazing tools
what's the value of that group to msr
tremendous
so the rise team has had tremendous
value both to microsoft research but
also
to the entire developer community so i
am quite familiar with the rise
the kind of work that rise does because
that's actually my home
research area in formal methods and
software engineering
um in programming languages and
i just have to share with you one story
because i know one of the
um great contributions that ryze has
has made for the developer developer
community has been code contracts
and if you look at what you would write
in one of those contracts it would be
requires clauses and insurers clauses
which are the equivalent of pre and post
conditions
and in my very own phd thesis
you will see requires and ensures in the
specification language that i actually
defined in my own thesis work and that
wasn't new to me
that was the kind of informal
specifications we were actually
asking undergraduates at mit to use
in the software engineering course that
i was a ta for
so way back in in decades ago
we were writing requires insurers closet
clauses we didn't have tool support the
way you know
the rise group has provided for
developers um so we come a long way
but let me let me speak uh more
specifically to
the benefit of the rise group for both
microsoft research and the developer
community
first of all they
really are world class
in terms of advancing all the research
areas i mentioned in terms
of formal methods and programming
languages
static and dynamic analysis testing
verification specification
and tool support there of all
and the one of the things that really
impresses me about the rise tool set is
that
they really build on each other so you
have
like z3 as this constraint solver on the
bottom which is the core
state-of-the-art you know theorem
improver and all these tools that sit on
top and work together
it's really impressive that this one
team has put this all together
and all of that is made available to the
developer community
and the developer community at the same
time
has been able to inspire the rise
community
the rise team to work on research
problems that i don't think they would
have thought of
had it not been for the feedback they
got from the developers
what are some of your favorite projects
at msr mike
one of my current favorites is actually
the the worldwide telescope to geoflow
um example and
before i explain why that's
before i explain that favorite i want to
tell you why
um it's one of my favorites and when i
talk about
research and computer science i like to
both the drivers of the questions
researchers ask in computer science
and also as i mentioned earlier the
impact
that one can have in doing research in
computer science
so i'd like to talk about science
drivers technology drivers and
societal drivers so there are deep
science
questions that researchers in computer
ask they ask questions like what is
computable
you know is this problem even solvable
by a computer
those kinds of deep questions continue
to intrigue theoretical computer
scientists
and as the nature of what a computer is
changes
we have to re-ask that question
technology drivers it's clear as
technology advances
we again have old questions that we have
to ask again
because they're going to be new answers
and new questions to ask
and then i think what's really new in
the field of computing or at least
recently is what i call societal drivers
the societal ground challenges like
health care
energy transportation education that
require advances to computer science
to actually help solve the problems
in their sectors and i believe that
advances of computer science can
actually transform the very conduct
of these other professions so in
healthcare for instance i really believe
that if
we were far out thinking in terms of
where this country or where the where
the world could be
in terms of personalized medicine and so
on
to achieve that vision we are going to
need advances in computer science so i
think now
instead of science technology and
society
as being drivers of computer science
research
i think they are also measures of
how much impact we have had as a field
we have um through our research advanced
science certainly our understanding of
computer science
but other sciences as well again biology
chemistry
material science astronomy um
and also through our research we have
certainly had an impact on technology
just look at microsoft look at all the
microsoft products and services and
devices
that we sell to our customers
a lot of the technology rests on
advances that we have made in research
and then finally
their society and i like to think that
through
our reach through our customers that we
reach through our technology
we certainly affect society in a very
direct manner
so getting back to the stories you asked
me one of the reasons i like the
worldwide telescope story
is it started as a pure science
research story not even computer science
it was about
the stars you know the galaxies
and you know one might even question
what why was why was that research going
on in microsoft research
but it was going on anyway and so
and of course it had to do with big data
in some sense and so
all of a sudden not all of a sudden but
over time
the research technology on the research
ideas
the ability to scale to the data that
the worldwide telescope needed to handle
the ability for citizen scientists to
actually contribute
all that technology could actually have
a very important interesting application
in excel
through power map and
and now through this
plug-in people
can look at crime statistics
in chicago and policy makers can make
intelligent decisions based on the
visualization that comes
out of all this data packaged in a way
that again
from data to knowledge to decision um
affects society so this is my science
technology society story
um another example along those lines
is some work that's more recently being
done on urban computing
so this is work um one example of this
is
is work called you air that
you zhang our new new tr-35
fellow from msra has been promoting
and the idea is again taking lots of
different data sources
whether it's weather um
road conditions their points of interest
in a city
the the human mobility patterns
and putting all these data streams
together
along with the few sensors that for
instance
are in beijing putting all the sensor
data
together to figure out what is the air
quality
of not the city but the street that i
live on in this city
and so this is an example of
multiple data streams coming together
using
machine learning and other data
analytics
algorithms to convey
to the mirror user but also to
policymakers
information that people can
use to decide well should i take
this route to work should i go to the
park
because maybe there's too much pollution
out there and the air will be bad
or for a policy maker to decide
maybe we should actually
focus on this particular neighborhood to
improve the air quality
because of the um the the the readings
that we have
from all this data so that's so that
urban computing example is again
um you know science technology and
society kind of coming together
um so that's another example there are a
lot of really
fun things going on um
there's uh i mean i can talk oh i don't
know how many stores do you want
um i i could talk i mean for instance i
was
just um at microsoft research asia a
couple weeks ago and they were showing
me their newest work on hair modeling so
it turns out that if you try to model
the human being
you know people work have worked really
hard on modeling the face
down to the level of you know the pores
in the skin
but it's really really hard to model
hair
um so if you look at a lot of the state
of the art
you'll see these heads without hair
because it's much easier to model the
skin
the eyebrows and so on i mean the eyes
and so on
but you won't see the hair so what the
these researchers have been doing
is actually tackling that problem and um
their most recent work is actually to
add a little dynamic so now you can
see the hair like blowing in the wind
so there are like fun things that that
um our
our researchers uh work on as well
what's going to surprise us in the
future
if i told you it wouldn't be a surprise
i think one of the
areas that i see a lot of
research in right now a lot of interest
by the consumer
and where we're going is in
what microsoft likes to call natural
user interfaces
i think that we have
already been seeing
our ability to get rid of the mouse
and maybe the keyboard at least the
physical one
and i think with speech input
with gesture in terms of
interacting with devices we are going to
more naturally interact with devices
with services and then of course
with each other thank you so much for
talking to us today jared
thank you